we're invisible no no cuz I I just I
didn't turn out for a second there on
the audio we have a message someone
wants to play you and you clicked you
how do you a boy is working now audio is
working now I believe in you Mike right
you know I can't play this token go away
go I can't like this person no no no no
wait people can't be your life dude
swish the screen so I can see you see me
give you your library nothing wait that
didn't change the camera at all any
seconds oh it's a 30-second thing no I
didn't look like a fool in 30s how do
you board
oh thanks you got a bags that's just not
my time control one or go high you know
if his only dream was ever to play my
color
it's not that day right right good luck
Mike I cheer you on
oh thank you thanks Billy yeah the first
one dagger so this is a test that we're
doing I'll blow my ass to us and here
comes the car variation can you believe
this I take it back
so this is the sort of a thing that
we're gonna start doing regularly with a
whoever our GM and res is so far might
start doing this I believe it's December
27th when you set up to do a stream so
if you guys are into it we will be
getting the GM and res here
whoever it is we always have one every
day throughout the year to come in here
and perform some super blitz for all to
see take the road but to kick it off
there's nobody better than Mike cover to
really get this stream happening what is
it going for check right let's go off
check my husband's very very scary
people are wondering what's happening
here
yeah also the studio we got Danny
Machuca the guy behind the camera was
obviously somewhere behind a camera
right now shunda the one and only
Emily Trask extraordinaire yeah so yeah
we're just testing this out today see if
this works so let us know if there's
like audio problems or things you can
get through hopefully we have like cool
graphics at some point and this becomes
sort of a regular thing today just trial
run it's one of those things you just
decide about one minute before you go in
there hey let's go in there and then you
just go in there oh look at that
neighbors ID yeah that's nobody can
flank the great Mike oh hey do you want
to challenge people ex villager he's
asking you're taking challengers no no
challenges just do one minute in baby
don't know three two that's not Mike
just 100 101 oh he's a he's the bullet
monster Oh bitsy I were starting to get
challenges that's what those like swords
I love that open for a primo good big
check coming up big truck challenging oh
yes three two against him nightmares
Expo drew are you challenging us I hope
so because ya know you gotta challenge
this ex villager guy he's our biggest
video on for checkmate Kenny said can I
sit can I sit can he sit he's taking all
the time so he sees it
how are you gonna do with that how you
gonna deal with that check and take a
sweet check check check
when you playing two against one dude
you got no chance but I would like and I
don't even like to this Queen I got a
gem a tomato you help me help me alone
and I like that they have that his name
is partner Ford yeah yeah challenge that
guy
he's our biggest fan good good
Mike's too good its own plus everybody
right good just go play positive which
this is 30 seconds 500 real deal I'm not
gonna get back Bo checkmated no I'm not
gonna get back from achievement I might
lose this game assistance yeah it's
easier to win when other people help you
I don't play d4 don't play j4 how did
you know I know is I have a runner I
know it's gonna play that very fast
don't checkmate bring the other rook in
and do the staircase checkmate you know
it you're the best teaching suggest
strikes again yes information I'm
thinking about it's 30 seconds all right
we'll play good masks X X it's already
it's aborted yeah no no a ball they're
smart
I was this you seen your opinion I did
not curse
that's not my that's not my style and
it's not my style
there's too much noise yeah yeah what do
I do
just I don't really want to go I'm gonna
get you I'm gonna get you thank you oh
this is not going good we believe in you
Mike thank you thank you thank you
right in the nick of time running lemak
Italia love it on rook didn't see that
one coming so the general plan to is
then whenever there's the Jay would res
is doing it those sort of pick their
time control and some will probably want
to play with challengers probably won't
we'll just let them just come in and
play some chess so we're gonna this
whole next year we're gonna have our
twitch stream we got a subscriber yeah
Wow a tier 1 sub whatever that is thank
you all mister cows oh my god I'm bad I
lost that's what that was at the end of
me there's only two that somebody
somebody got the point somebody got that
man there so we have a subscribe to your
one sub compliance wait wait yeah cacao
sees their user - Musa
cleans the club that sounds like
flatmates might rather be watching yeah
you guys can also if you want you guys
can play with Emily Trask Danny Machuca
or Jonathan Ross but mostly my comer cuz
he's the man I was the man on my
pedestal I got my post well how soon
before again on NPR I see we have a lot
of mpr fans out oh yes yes I got big big
story coming up yet you were just at
least tell us about tell them a little
bit what it all about comes rode Chesley
we're gonna try to win the title again
this year very exciting stuff very
exciting got some new additions and we
board the people every part Castle
always have to announce castling or else
it's not official this is so thirty-six
people watching yeah my bad for just
render we decided to sit down turn the
camera oh I'm about ready to get
checkmated I needed to play something
else
but not that one so you guys have any
questions or the HS book or my cover how
many times does a guy have to resign let
us know we are here here we got one
challenger yeah it click on it twitch
that's him play him parents you got a
Voyager you wanna play the 100 this
isn't mr. 100 leaders so does this mean
there is no chance he will accept my
challenge I am NOT a good chess player
he should not fear me okay come on this
guy's weak I will
industry our heroism he's a gentleman
he's not listening so now we can
actually say what we really think about
all right yes here's the official color
variation was this ever published in
London yes yes July 1998 in chest life
so if you have that magazine look it up
I'm in Larry Evans's yeah what do you do
here just go back go back
yeah I see how far behind this is yeah
no way you've achieved in one minute no
way probably in three minutes you can
cheat yeah yeah we're still slow you
down you can't do it every book whose
idea was this
well Mike just comes into work some days
he says hey put me on the air on the air
that's all it takes
it's not even a joke that's like you
just came in let's do a show start at
which thing let's go in the air and test
it out I'm waiting right I got a 12
second bonus on this guy so far so good
so far so good I like Ian Mike Emery
screaming oh my god here comes a check
here comes a check he'll know it's not
good some people always stop stepworth
you can't handle that one oh he would
love to play you but he just cannot
handle actually she'd be someone like
comers okay okay so that's gonna happen
Jonathan will be a grandmaster every
time no yeah yeah damn always there
victorious all right who else we got
mohamad 73 our app so Balu Lee tell at
73 Center check this gets past this
heart he's taking 100 challenges no guys
come on
yeah I am playing I am playing the
people I don't want some of this
they don't know what they're up against
Mike just get out of here
go Ronnie let me break back in a little
bit it was a Czech girl as a trick good
trick
this guy's just way too fast go in there
take in the long way every X villager
thank you for the game this guy is just
too fast I just want to quit one second
by this guy you like my you like my
little plan he's gonna owe you anything
to get that pawn you're never getting
that pond you're never getting my slowed
down right that one whole minute so if
you guys can chill out what do you think
you're playing take it take it take it
something takes it forget that pond I oh
I have to do the yes forest energy to
play win over your nights on the optimal
square yes microwaving a 15 thank you
you can't catch me
I wanna come back
I was never losing yeah we need to say
that PG and all that clearly two three
one tomorrow see how you don't owe three
plus one never never never no that's
acts villager again you want to fight
him again let me play to 1692 three one
play that guy it's good oh yeah twenty
minutes so plus one second yeah alright
oh shoot okay now yeah just look they're
kidding
all right so this everybody is Perry
Coulson best associate extraordinaire
and what do you do around not remember
that guy got forked you're not okay now
fast is my camera theory no this is it
yeah don't help me cuz I want you that's
not fair well it's not fair no but
nothing's fair your life you know they
have to explain this to my children
every day
mr. on stuff for a game sure yes this
trash gopher no you wanna know what my
writing it
what's your rating 900 I hate you I
[Music]
think you thought wait maybe duh my
lunches take it take it take it I don't
know about us I'm doing talking probably
five minutes I'll be talking I'll talk a
whole bunch I'm gonna play well I'll
just talk a little more time enjoy
you're gonna place your on my normal
time control is like three minutes but
probably if I'm talking five minutes but
against the axe villager specifically
the accident yeah he was our number one
guy who look at look at the chat was
absolute your axle yeah okay
we're a full 10 seconds what's happening
here what goes in right no no Ruth is
hanging do what now yeah take some good
show you have to Ellen they worked out
well we down app I know it's even isn't
it kids to cheer up a bun he's not take
it take it take a card I'm gonna kind
words mr. X villager we got 35 I think
our peoples like oh so can you guys
before my chest lead you over to my
chest I don't know but in here some
people see it here yeah I'm out will you
do it - no it just ends the stream and
then we have to pull the Rebecca I don't
know you could change it in the velvet
stream for sure did he do it you might
want to do it yeah just say people have
twitch how do we change her how do we
change the title of the show well out of
the 35 ones done
I take one oh no don't take cuz that
don't dance the root you big-time twitch
super guru yeah okay also your life
right now so stop swearing and how do we
change the title how do I change the and
I'm gonna change the title of a twitch
broadcast and when you walk in front of
that camera you're on the screen which
is fine we're all everyone itching for
too late no this is the computer right
just dream info on the page I think you
can change the title in the middle of
the stream that will update no problem
you can just stream info on the page
twitch TV slash dashboard okay I'm gonna
play X villager wait I have to play this
weird angle super gamer Mouse hey blue
chance yeah reason this was very
impromptu we're using the Danny Huachuca
setup here so we got superior good luck
I have muted the streams like that there
you go this is this is for you yeah I
assume there's most people play like it
should be three Queen d2 and castlelong
in this sort of line and this particular
line um what do I do
alright I believe after Bishop g2 I play
stuff like Knight to f6 I will probably
play the line where they take on d4 and
just
and bring myself out
that's my intention I don't know this
movie for not that I know this at all
this is the sort of thing we do when you
get some random position people just
don't play a fool I think instead of a
for usually they've castled and then
they play Bishop Jeff for here so now
that the pawns on a four and then I
can't go to a 4 I play Queen to b6 here
take that pill castle no Aaron I guess
I'll all right I get my stuff out hello
he plays Bishop to g5 maybe I'll run
away
yeah no you have been what here was like
lamb go forward how can you change the
title of stream
mm hey what are we doing here we stop it
around of the night guys nothing
settlement you've got a different
streamline yeah he's watching Kings
crusher he's kind of so do you put light
chesley on the thing yeah I don't know
if it takes like a minute to update or
paint all right cool move his Queen
somewhere I've got an achievement for
changing the stream title nice and you
an achievement
yes achieved something today yeah
what is it saying usually it's probably
their chat is there so we'll watch it
later under pressure
sure look I can play Knight to c4 and he
might take it and I'll check him in with
his queen
you never know you never know until you
put it there and just date him he's on
to me
what second you wait wait 30 seconds
every move okay so he's dammit I mean
not like Michael Terry is even helping
for him
Oh this thing how do I take it yeah II
understand b3 we'll see what he comes up
with maybe us to play like Bishop d2
should be some sort of attack this thing
again like for my bishop bagging this
thing's effect right you can always play
Bishop takes pollen or whatever yeah but
then you'll take my bishop that's
upsetting oh yeah you don't want to tell
you don't wanna Michael no and there's a
chicken right I saw it so he might take
my bishop that was upset
look see he's gonna play oh you are
well first of all I'm just gonna take
this thing I don't see another good
wasted objective oh okay so we need to
like join me yeah joined this okay so
all you gotta do is true we also need
the same shadow music like yeah I'm
gonna take this yes this thing moves
away nobody feels good
um secret exit have to do some of them
and I was probably coming upon by taking
and putting a brick here don't know if I
want to try for more like protect this
and I'm a simple guy though Oh work out
three okay hopefully he doesn't wait 36
yeah yeah no that's got to be jungle
open
yeah I'm sure I'm not gonna play well
this mostly focus on trying to get us
they did it you did it on Mike don't
cheat against alright whatever
last thing yeah you could've got way
more so this is on twitch you're trying
to get it on VHS it's all over the place
yeah so we can get it something that
shows up somehow on my chest that work
and that's how a lot of people will
actually see that we're you know
streaming and doing whatever those
having their okay yes you sit down if he
takes us I'm not actually sure how I'm
taking back just played some move you
should just wait yeah I didn't I didn't
play well or anything but I'm just
slowly it's lagging people so it's
always been my desire to flag
Thanks oh wait you a cute villager who
can checkmate you checkmate oh no I got
checkmated
that's okay checkmate in shock just
straight up got checkmate yeah Bobby
well she's only one not on stream right
now get her in there is that Beth Deakin
bringing rain is a party come on in mess
come play chess against the fans what's
happening here I'm not paying any
attention to spoon but I made a pre move
so that'll show that I deeply thought
virus doesn't mean oh you got checked
you're using I lost
oh my guys I got checked one time what's
happening here see that's good no this
will be great well I'll be happy
oh I'll end up winning the game on time
he'll end up that roulade some lady
ain't do that everybody's gonna be happy
I'll see you through singing what the
way but tell me what's happening when I
take it what do you mean by forever I
haven't been paying a test for ever but
now you do it now you can't he knows the
game you take and he goes he goes
f7 right no no he can't do you play with
Jason fine whatever
easy win thank you who's the next
challenge this guy is taking over
beginner breakdown starting only 1930 I
don't want to
Oh way up here right now me for a while
he wants to play crazy house no radio
special will slay this 3+3 thing a
casual or you could play yeah right yeah
it's only Wi-Fi might do in tonight
soldier take a good nap so whose idea
was this was yours Michael of course
who's gonna actually give yes thank you
for the game mr. X villagers good yay
thank you yes good job
now obviously the point is to have a gym
here with an actual serious environment
deep insightful game people wanna see
class play but uh yeah right this right
we're doing the real real fun job but
they'll come in here and let me every so
often don't try to play you in the Lexus
way the people try too hard you will
still win but you guys are great
you're gonna sound I think we need to
register out there thank you sir but I
need as Jesse good job email he used
does he probably one on there
well know what humility but you did it
this like recently yeah you guys can put
that in the title but it looks like new
I'm not loving dating the title although
I like an achievement
yeah I got a treatment for it so says I
put three experts imagine ages magic
it's that's all you need it they know it
doesn't restrict your chest plate is
used to yesterday I guess that's the see
what's happening here mr. Barrow some
funny chess good you know whatever
rating we end up with we'll just tell
the grandmasters well this is casual
people then this guy challenged me to
nominative game that's if you want my
cover
do I have mo minute challenge I'll play
five minutes Emily I'll just stand in
the background slightly off do whatever
whatever you get up whatever you give up
I need to have been I've been away from
the chap us been waiting long hopefully
have will be very nice I need to get
back find the chat those are my people
no I don't know they know yeah don't
tell me oh he didn't find it I just
wanted maybe people is this for real
are we offline oh maybe I'm logged into
something different oh maybe that's why
we can't change it oh you're not
changing it yeah STL Cheska
you're doing it on our secret don't tell
everybody the name of it oh so I have to
log into the other account do you have
this account Logan yeah probably
you're on say we're offline also learn
well so I don't sell people our secret
name even if they know already
oh yeah not a possum was just joking
guys think funny one spectator oh stop
watching me no work its viewership is
plummeting
once we get on my chest we're go sky
rocket here check you got this isn't is
nice hanging now we're using the account
that we were trying to use I just think
we we use a lot of accounts some of them
are private for our own use I guess but
yeah this is the main account this is
where we'll be streaming all the stuff
when the grandmasters are here and Farah
Cobian on the 27th he'll be here and
then every couple of weeks we'll get
people in here at some point we might
try to establish some sort of regular
stream where we have a set time people
come in but it's quite brand new so
we're just rolling with whatever happens
that's bummer dude you're oh I could
have played need to put in the total you
won't go to the front page
yeah we're just we need to put in the
title of ein our last ALJ's live account
so we we're looking into it so they keep
your help no joke chess is actually
doing the best job of helping us get
this set up which is all we're here to
do today is really figure out these
little details that we don't know about
you want to tell my future dream
Esther's are scheduled on a 27th
in need to see what puts me into the
best position here to be on the camera
I'm not in a good position you get
closer des no I need to wait 30 get away
from me no I'm getting closer to their
lies above the screen okay I get for you
again
well don't rematch them used to shop for
you okay now I got this guy he's easy
or we'll play somebody else I think I
want but I want I need sir so this way
click on that
whoa this one oh oh I thought that was
like a streamer they we're doing money
if we're actually streaming or something
we don't know that you can do I can't
pick somebody and so that's our that's
our favorite guy you decide yet but yeah
yeah but there's also a lot of like
other people who yeah well this might be
this means sadly the last game here for
mr. X villager cuz he's X villagers yeah
well no is it this or North but yeah
Jerry's he's X villager what time is it
a minor place it's 11:00 at night here
in Norway that's the guy that you're
going at what time so if he has a stream
muted that you won't hear so I guess
it's 11:00 at night in Norway it is 4:00
p.m. the same less now you put it upon
no God till we get off I guess huh
yeah we got no real set plans it was
just show up turn the camera on
operation please yes yes I think I was
wrong yeah we're working on getting the
title fixed we got our tech guy Danny
Machuca
running around he's running around
somewhere he's looking into it it'll be
fixed this might take a little bit my
man all right what's happening you
crushing him easily
no yes you were him me me I mean I would
never talked about this is 4 p.m. over
there oh yeah I think you're writing
that in the chat tell me what to play
Joe no I don't cheat when they don't
know the answer
[Music]
it easily stood out to me that and would
you mind switching to the dark theme I
hate the dark thing but we can do it
well yeah I mean I like it I live my
life in the light but if people like
dark intense arundo sacrament we can do
it our board things yep hey Kyle Webber
I'm in the stream why don't they like I
like just what's your language I'm like
chess island yeah
just come stand behind this camera yeah
we're honest we're on dad we're just
practicing we're at our official chess
club
oh yeah here come here watch on here no
the camera is on the computer oh that's
right here I'm yeah yeah I mean
eventually we'll have it so we're using
the professional setup but we got likes
probably stuff back here we're figuring
everything out this is the figure it out
stream play on Twitch are people
complaining that you've got like a bit
sir next year nobody cares because I'm
not really cheating so much not so much
at some point you made everybody say hi
to Kyle below and I am the coordinators
yeah that's just okay what's your rating
pal that's good I have not you know he's
a blitz monster 16 I'll use Perry's
answer what are you trying to do here
leaving six no we're trying to do you
need a little more experience just
teaching and playing talking before you
can oh yeah no I just grasp the deep
subtleties behind my tactical wizardry
but basically yeah you know I'll be
showing up for gonna break down to learn
ways to heckle me effectively
okay what was my idea yeah take on c6
well doesn't work everyone
I do agree with the coos can't stay in
the dark I feel like most people do
prefer a dark I don't really understand
what don't just get yeah but I can't
change it back for the time but okay
well can you guys okay oh there's a
great move here somewhere
it's in there dude thank you
five seconds figure it out from soft is
it fault it did you update this we're on
my chest
no way go to my chest right now nobody
is streaming on my chest
two minutes two heads up okay yeah two
minutes then just refers to like a
fairly busy superior booze my chest aunt
which the same time yeah okay no we got
Ginsberg's is the same check right I
mean I want to be looking at like two or
three different chats at any given time
yes obviously wait here and our YouTube
community is yeah yeah whatever it is
yeah yeah how do I give more money to
damage was you know a thicker decent
first what no I do not want to take on
the six tactical just bullet specialist
somewhere may why do I just let go
alright playing and someone please as a
soozluecke double-oh-seven what is your
tell us your name old for challenge us
to one minute you might get to play the
legendary Mike comer who isn't one
minute specialist here at the chest but
goes you know I'm me too I also hope
that I get back right Jonathan
oh we're all these emojis Lee I don't
know anything they say like don't tell
me what to do except I should probably
can't hear that you're the Emoto I
refuse until it's time slightly sleepy
sleepy
boring what's that face
yeah no residents just song my queen and
nobody cared
okay or nobody's streaming we fresh with
their pressures all right no no nobody
is true so did wait but it still says
here
do I have to refresh to see this no
that's not changed I talked to someone
from my chest
Oh supposed to whitelist this stream and
we're supposed to be on there all right
look at that yeah I couldn't even play
nine maybe what the hell all of our
challenges variants and does STL chess
club provide online or skype private
lessons or is it really over the board
club anyway it's very first five books
this is gonna be the best thing never
ever do you do because everyone's gonna
watch online Skype lessons yeah if you
do if you are interested in less than
sending eww through here at the club or
on skype we really only have one person
that does it let's send it in email to
info and this guy on club dot org I can
type that into the chat here you can get
one more email info access is going down
in a minute
oh so spam us with one minute challenges
emailed the link that I just sent in
maybe you'll get a will put her best
person on it Danny but you guys see you
guys after the new year I know you can
having every new year yeah you guys are
visible in light chest I know let's see
oh we are
yeah you are yeah business does it does
London just thank you no that's a
replace London because he's you know
that person with London chest Pisces no
no this makes sense son and I'm also a
bad person
well we all know that's the only kind of
person that plays the system yeah listen
lay in the dark keep over the London
old-fashioned stress so let's see Oh our
viewership is skyrocketing up in 53
people they like Cola HS and yeah well
we're just waiting for it to get to like
100 so we can bring back my Hummer as I
think we're ready for EM well yeah maybe
I'll have to play again we will take it
Perry Beckett I'll get in there I don't
know for anybody that's new we are doing
any test stream I just I'll be repeating
it a few times we're gonna get the all
the German res to come and play some
chess hopefully give you deep insightful
analysis no one's bring back the game
and I hear he's coming the who the K man
Special K oh yeah
Mikey K got it got it that kinda yeah I
guess so yeah so it'll be bar we'll be
doing it early 27th time unknown to me
there will be opportunities for all the
GM's res here comin in play so expect a
lot more twitch streams oh my not only
nice as a first stream so things are
wrong if audios wrong video could be
better just tell us stuff we do whatever
you guys want
that's what we're about here who is the
current Jimenez it is vara Cobian so
yeah we will be you'll be doing this I
guess six days he'll be he'll be here so
if you're coming to the lectures its far
Akopian right now um an Emily Trask is
on chat she can start telling you the
list of upcoming Grand Master's mmm who
is next
it's probably like Dinesh boorish again
we got a ton of school left coming in
February we also got Pepe cuenca for the
first time ever I'm very excited about
that dance through is as well you could
just tell me that guys very excited yeah
we got some new faces
well you have some new faces Stevens urk
will be new this next upcoming year on
decent year and he's a GM no yes so um
you have some new people
oh I thought you were saying you had to
take on before but that's you sure took
them before we ran a list of mix GM's
and Chet Emily Trask
where you guys from Hanging Rock mmm
well she took my mic away to in my rug
what are you talking about how it's a
nice change
yeah hmm the exchange is not 71 people
yeah when we get to 100 we're bringing
my kid that's the that's the deal
I should play we got Mike he's just
waiting I'm not a grandmaster said I
guess let's Emily dress okay I think
people are excited for Pepe I know I am
yeah great
oh my gosh no no well now he's gonna
check me out too but gosh it's too easy
that's to you too easy to defend that
yeah I'm just going oh my gosh that's
mean one dude okay
oh my god it I get me everything okay
all right I'm not are people challenging
us get in there what's happening here
say say here watch watch that but listen
sit unnaturally close to me okay
about a 1 minutes that's good where's
Mike it's all one minute challenges I
can't do that and this guy's provisional
yeah this is a one plus one so Mike
won't take it I'll take it Honda Accord
we got Johnson trots up here one minute
game let's go
yeah no not the load that one minute
game but it's also plus one so I have no
idea how to do a win baby okay oh this
one I'll take that beep on hopefully a
ticket
there yes what about your crush you know
so this person doesn't have a rating
which is always interesting you know I
guess I'd sure I guess I should've
played here that's what I was thinking
but yeah took me like one second to
adjust what's whatever's going on here
nope nope doesn't leave his head spun do
it here we go it's a lot of sense yeah
take it let go here [ __ ]
yep that's you stopped it don't you do
it again there you go Shane off work
there lose everything
No I thought he could take with Erick
there didn't do it
I'm also checking this night now
you predicted that I already put a rock
on CA during some sort of stuff what is
he doing I should be careful yeah you
never know and like you never know what
he might do to me there should be a
little bit go might be rook to ca this
threatens night two before it does
didn't stop me check yeah okay it's
fallen apart from mr. Honda Accord the
GM Jonathan trance check off you promote
he's so strong
okay people do that so tell see there so
let's go get a tea like we got a lot of
a few oh thank goodness for me alright
we got like all these one-minute
challenges good so many challenges that
moved in making sense but they won me a
piece so I won't complain but you
playing one minute one plus one mr.
Hunnicutt yeah I knew you wouldn't take
it so I grabbed it so I took I got that
out of the way for you towards up okay
just step aside all right you're off the
clock you guys kiss ya what the most
popular responses to e4 and D for guy
hey that's me
wait does casual mean not ready did yes
yeah Oh Mike they're all casual wait one
two three four five six seven eight nine
she lists all of them casual come on you
guys know Mike at all let's go out and
play for keeps
yeah yeah yeah wow so you're gonna
ignore eat challenges and just some rain
head guys raided it is crazy to me I
don't know that I mean nobody wants to
lose the ring place Mike I get it well
we're taking off humiliated
the other one thing you should know
about Mike he plays for checkmate
there's nothing nothing else going on he
is here to checkmate you he's got
nothing else your king name of the game
checkmate ends he's coming for your king
I don't like that Lonnie what's my phone
you got shucks
so I guess we need all these like cheers
and you know goal bunch of stuff I don't
know how it works it's raining it all
right we were up to 90 people watching
watch me lose a Mario I had us Bishop I
still got the bishop unless it's a trick
not a try the dome let's see the people
the plays about people
comer special that's right that's what
you think that's real at Jesslyn okay
good job Trask if it just put it I liked
it it was you Danny fire
let's give them this thing and get on
with the show
all my work is a great day yeah you know
Steve hey up five seconds figure this
out I was reading the title like that
cracked view I'm gonna be all right got
that come on come on come on come on you
go faster dude playing is the name of
the game flag up this is gonna be tough
now he knows the staircase very
disappointing
all right okay we had nine challenges
now come on hope you got some rain in
your life you play one minute that thing
that's too long
like x1 you're gonna redeem Leon it here
got to the Lord
spreading his wings he's also a very
successful streamer I love history I
thought you had a trick I thought you
gonna take on c4 and Matt I never saw a
blood loss was that the first loss am I
the only one that would never lost you
can never know we're we're playing with
GM next door named we've never lost a
game in our life we are crushing it
today I got this game yeah ez game ez
that's what I needed I needed that I'll
look at this check coming up your focus
and things now mr. Jack needs a little
bit and then that's it right that's that
free move that yeah just give it up just
give it up okay man doesn't play casual
hey man hey man I got a play that came
in as I came into the con the kill a
chair misery boom ah Who am I 2085
where's the important yeah right faster
fast fast yeah that's not too bad
check them doubles pawns get that going
get that going
everyone viewers we did it yes we
brought on drew that Dennis Lou
thus ensuring that emoji that looks just
like the room sure it is probably the
failfish yeah that's you right the
filter yeah I got a I got a buddy and
thank you thank you thank you just gotta
keep building yeah to know that we do
have a lot of good people I should just
keep repeating this is sort of a
practice stream for when we get all the
teams
rest here so far the 27th will be
playing some blitz hopefully against the
pans will kind of let him pick the time
controller he likes to play so you know
most channels they have a way you can
watch the grandmasters play blitz it's
always my one of my favorite things and
we got to get it going on our own stream
here so we'll get far playing blitz so
we'll get all the other GM you residence
players lists and in every now and then
you know Mike and I'll stop by Barry
will stop by Dennis it's not mine we're
all here to play chess why no variance
so yeah there yeah no variance oh we got
a man who plays the most variants here
just love Emily trash Dennis Dennis
don't play for I mean I'm sure there's
people here that would go support yes
sure there's people that will play a
very street bullet yeah if the
interference distress play Boy Scouts
well just know we have uh gasps okay my
master was they don't have a mistake
well I mean if we count like my lesson
no but like Caleb dim be Lama Lord he
plays the trick let's play somebody did
you guys think he's in the calendar guy
yes see if he knows what to do know what
Mike hasn't heard gasser story about how
he saw this for the first time and then
just refuted it over the board so not
everyone has a high opinion but always
take always take one please crush this
guy
so far so good right so perhaps people
have seen Caleb on our YouTube channel
mr. Calum Demi you can look him up he's
got YouTube videos we streams all the
time I want to play variant with law and
favorite hockey team those dirty draw
yeah play better come on
Caleb I gave you this guy's good yeah
he's like 2100 rated USC oh I don't mind
that check I don't mind it so yeah yeah
well worth watching I understand for the
same for the same I've seen dad check
names but Emily trusk are you watching
the chances they've been great I also
want to say thank you to all the Jeff
because if just not right go son you
guys haven't made Emily trust work hard
deleting all of your posts look at all
my past he's saying no we haven't had to
which is like this guy stay on the track
we want Emily trash yeah Emily Emily
trust no oh
does he know this you know why doesn't
know this checkmate come on you're in
the wrong spot
wow you're you're gonna draw this guy
you're gonna draw the line Lord
I'm so good at it we're not buddies I
didn't see that in seconds Joy's expert
says master yeah yeah five plus 50
seconds that's awesome
all right thank you came up nobody knows
except for everybody in this room you
were supposed to have a match against
the other Caleb that works here is so we
got a hopefully if any will be true
I would hate for people to go get that
info at account it starts you coming in
yeah why the internet nerd he's been
played on a joke where is he yeah you
done your 1900 play no joke hi yeah yeah
three two that's more year nine stuff
yeah oh my gosh never seen before it
beautiful oh my gosh you gonna play my
dear that was awesome all right
yeah chaos oh my get this dude you got
this all right so this is Perry Coulson
here not that anybody doesn't know who
is this guy oh just as I say it I said
who is this guy just a chess so stealing
about one person would just associate
that's all the only and only Perry
that's you there's also if I just admin
okay let's not cheat this game and then
when no no stops looking I think you
might have been the one who called oh
nice alright thank you no joke if that
is true what is his USEF what's your
reading Oh
hundred hundred yeah on a good day
twelve hundred
that serves every year to me that stuff
to me don't think it's that bad of me
what's what's so bad about it first does
that even mean okay take this guys you
can take the other better take this guy
good idea
in stalemates then you want my comer if
you a commerce department see this is
why you need to play one with it yeah
this was a right hand it's still waiting
for now probably probably Bishop a
textbook yeah that's what we're sorry
yeah good good
he's probably just gonna say it he's
consistent be fun like we do rejected
again pre-movie see ya all these long
numbers mister Alice we want I barely
know the rules
who's that is that you mr. navona
Raymond I can win a pawn back this is
the person that you should play somebody
called I barely know the rules you got
this now you want to throw in the Chuck
so throw them the check now yeah all
right just a little check all right and
then hopefully I'll block with the room
trade the rook to take the pawn and then
you got
yeah beautiful beautiful color now your
aunt do anything well you go back oh you
gotta get that you got to get that porn
on the ones
take this guy yeah you got no roof
breaks through I'll do it
well he's gonna go down here is a six
push these Knicks you got this do
whatever you want if you were if you
were happy with that without that
no I was not happy without that pond
okay Mike's just value freedom of
expression I shouldn't get those
together here's your game it's your life
would you be much check the last it was
good right you march your king to c5
that starts a damn seven the grand
master volume and then watch this he's
gonna play a whatever then a I and then
we put your [ __ ] up there this is the
moment you want to win the game from
right you can't speak in numbers there's
no one I can speak answers pressure
that's all and then go here right until
now to go fishing I'm busy otherwise to
somehow saw through our deep deep didn't
realize oh now you do it yeah but no
he's gonna joke don't take that pot or
else he's gonna pin you okay so just
move this guy up right put your fault
all right you tidy up beautiful so you
put the other guy on the lights are you
this guy right here your other poem this
guy right here who's on the lake
squaring unity that's true light you are
so like yourself and then get ready okay
is the audio quite lifelike isn't way to
up watching on our discord what's a
discord seven peaks and something else I
noticed which ones there please
and blue this one he's got 20 seconds
he's umbrellas Boomhauer he's got two
seconds you better plate late boost six
six King just move that pole up no good
do whatever you're screwed now this
right here mana yeah so we're still here
even though I change a tire that was a
good move yeah we're screwed
where's chess openings explain that's
been taught by Jim McLoughlin lately um
I had a baby and then he took my job he
said oh you've been you've been
recognized that as LaRue yeah Morgan
Stanley made like Mike Hummer nobody can
know this is an easy draw for Mike but
that's just a stalemate
we still need to go into the corner very
you cares - yeah use somebody's name out
you want to play yeah all right let's
see what's going on place if you don't
want the Internet dirt I don't know I
don't know nose watching us so he wants
to play okay yeah every position is good
he's like an expert yeah thank you know
Jonas for the Game Boy
I'm pretty close to height on the
Cornell whip ah yeah okay here Lee know
the rules also else to play I'll play
barely know another way Noma yeah
hopefully it's a one minute
we move we a one week move deserves
another huh whoa you playing Danny which
I knew is hey Danny you over there
playing this looks like a but you know
oh you play like magnets this is a
variant or something he plays like
Magnus for people that have seen
Magnus's stream this looks like a
familiar opening though I used to like
these
oh maybe I should enjoy I want to be on
that side yeah he is this guy is too
strong for me well WI you Jake
TT manic look back there yeah yeah I
think of ya be 585 that's thematic here
in this opening and then you know you're
gonna lose goes yeah Vegas 85
I agree H but I bet ya whichever one
that is either the king and queen yeah
sure it is
is this any good this you know it was
core stuff but Magnus crushes like he
was playing in Elijah's arena and he was
like just crushing all the grandmasters
do whatever he can play like this is
just people
we can joke around in the new
settlements like HSN were just going on
an adventure
knights called adventures if you move
the deep honest protector oh yeah that's
oh my god yeah take it though cuz you
get the night beautiful land
yeah that one exactly what happened know
these guys better than jaws Maurice and
Jen okay don't get checkmated okay I
don't know why 76 checkmate that's not
quite I'm playing here
g6 is not my mate neck like it's my be
my be close but yeah always gonna play
rook up once where there's nothing
you got this dude yeah yeah okay okay I
don't know okay can you see me like
which I love yeah as always the where's
my race yeah that one quiet moves
am I playing this guy dogs oh well do
much I'm gonna play one game in London
are you gonna play Danny we must anymore
be huh
behind the yeah yeah Danny hates playing
shadows all right Thank You Internet
nerd yeah
boo-ki legendary cottages alright my
turn and then let's see no supernova 30
second theory so next to me right read
that
to me go that's a fish try non-teflon
will do one tough one yeah you're done
I'll play mister get done I'm done
I know a little nervous for I am only a
1600 provisional all right here's my
newest thing groom crow gambit and I
accept it I'm just letting you know you
Castle I'm taking it taking your pot all
right
that's the deal and good people don't do
this cuz black it's way too active but I
did it and the main move is actually
might say six people play Bishop to g4
here if you play f3 you can take or not
take alright he's teaching fools
something alright the Dana Machuca line
goes Bishop g4 and after after E you
take even though most people moved in a
way damn you shouldn't really get enough
compensation there's like but most
people don't play this way as white
because black is really active and
bonuses stuff Bishop will go to chief or
after f3 goes back to f5 and they play
like you five just break over the center
and crush you okay um feel slightly slow
what I want to do is just get my Bishop
Allen castle and say that I'm up upon if
I can get all this stuff in and
hopefully there's no nasty stuff
happening to me I get everything in so I
got to Castle I'm off upon yes okay
alright where's he going
I don't know he's going yeah usually
they try to create some sort of more
pressure against you there's ways he's
always gonna be playing 45 a lot earlier
what's Jeff saying Thank You Jonathan
the except every time there's no the
fortnight that I don't know
good but I I just told my son you can't
play it this good idea that's all I know
about it it was banned in train
fortnight what what for is it like the
founder mm just put yourself in places
so now I don't really know I'm doing I'm
doing my typical I've played the opening
great I'm a genius
now some ill games don't care anymore
hmm okay I got my opening advantage not
letting your son play is a goodness so
score one for either of the year this
yeah if you only knew the Christmas
presents I'm buying this year the best I
thought you don't buy Christmas presents
I thought they were delivered by
somebody um those are as well we get
them selves in there and you take all
the credit
yeah that was all dad yeah what am i
doing what am i doing hey come on get th
you do not do anything
Brooksie to Roxy well and just say yes
I'm up on still so there's a moment on a
movie yeah well that's obviously my
strengthen chest is just the opener you
Lynn you to some mil game whatever
what's happening takes off take stuff
I'm up a bun my comer always taught me
in here at the pawn trade yep so it's
always easy so it's just like just as
easy we're back on trade good so here we
are I'm not the bun you can trade claims
Wow
tell me how many not three I'll take
double pawns you know so you won't
double palm I'm thinking of queen day
six I guess I have a ton of time this is
like a forever gaming forever situation
might be coming in looking to be three
at some point maybe I should take some
measure against it I don't know
what'd I miss well anyway why are you
vacating at all your area
no your area you're attacking blue
technically they're just play
fighting Isis users that were kaizen
yeah I don't think he's nuclear okay hey
do I just challenge and wait or yeah
challenge await challenge or what huh
let me toast your name in the chat it
does seem to steal Tesla says challenge
and we together be the neighbor the
title yes I can play Queen e2 that's one
look out
pin sense Danny said it I do it Quincy -
then yeah come on Quincy - I'm up on sir
so you think he's gonna take his kaput
you 5 Homer taking your background check
me dude okay I'm careful on flesh or is
there some super professional g4 stuff
okay okay it's not professional so easy
these Queen c7 a double tech and no this
is a test
that's a double attack queen of the pun
so I took fun okay that is what a double
attack looks like now that okay that was
was what two pawns sir I'm the best
chefs master 2410 the 11th challenge
there was your we have acknowledged
played some games at the same time no
that's too much too much for the viewers
so they couldn't if I keep trying to
trade this we just going to keep trying
so Queen the be three again yeah
Queen to be oh yeah you said it you said
I checked whenever you see a check it's
like how hard is it now you can check
them rings this doesn't look good -
because whatever oh wow trained it I
love trading he's got to play rook to b8
she's gotta do it I just get the you
know but what do you place here what do
I play
oh now you're playing keep that close
I'm gonna take this thing this week I
have more puns yeah give it up you're
done yeah yeah get the writing on the
wall
why would just be fine no no ma'am now
you give him so much compensation we're
just gonna get all past each part no oh
you got one buddy I'm gonna take it yeah
there's a lot of people in the queue um
we do look forward to playing you okay
well there's this guy so much
compensation because I play the opening
right and then I just kind of like you
know teach yeah
well see you lost I don't know who knows
knows how many queens he'll be up to me
yes who's playing next chess master 2410
really wants to play looks like over X
villagers is also a check done exciting
and I'm no Caleb Danby I make Queens
yeah and then I go here hopefully that's
a good diagonal for Queen hopefully
what's up Chris they'll set it up yeah
he knows we can't just set it up and
play the loser let's print or freezer
how many people would watch Mike for
snare this scheme or you guys watch
Andrew tank two passes to fit your disc
isn't too fast no slow we have you sorry
swishing you good luck thank you
I need all the good graces I can get
half points so you don't have to did I
say that now Matt I play it so slow my
career would have been ridiculous yeah
oh great agreed agreed
I know I don't keep saying like you
can't post stuff dude you like some
reasons with what I can't say the reason
because it the reason it said that he
can't say that is what Andrew my car
would have been bigness I don't know I
wanted to ban that quote we loud it got
it good call videos yeah thanks all
right I'm not gonna come back that's all
I can say
like freezer reason I'm crushing them
I'm crushing them Oh
yeah I got 25 oh my god my nights
trapped please say I'm my dress oh yeah
just but he's gonna go make a cookie
thing watch this
don't watch it please there's a little
hook just a little hop just a little
hope just yeah you're fine X villager
yeah you're fine
you are please let me take your up porno
Queen Queen Queen wait just get up there
go quick oh my god hey how many times I
have to press Queen yeah up to 110 for
viewership blues dude frosya that was
very very very the game freezer sounds
oh yeah good game freezer good game you
played well you played well yeah I
barely know the rules that's not there
are you thank God I can finally beat
somebody hell wish as guys the water
right we still provisional on the game
looks like you're panicking slightly
they say slight it might say triple is
old strip Allah spawns really knows the
rules
yeah hey here's an idea triple pawns are
bad buddy Russian this guy my gosh my
weak squares my weak squares get so much
this room you want it you got it
this is one time only one time only
we're speaking about cancers now oh my
god you agree
castle into the footer yes open to them
I be risk oh you want my reassurance
okay so I must be playing at least my
coverings another yeah when I talk about
this anywhere though the best square
this is not going good as with not going
checked on yes also he's up like a
thousand seconds
he used to got half his time so far in
your luggage that's kind of this guy is
a little too good yeah we got a WCM
maybe in the tap asking you if you think
Magnus could draw you if you gave him
real guts then Stu mate seems a little
fun alright that's all I wanted to still
make it get in the corner
I need some way I can beat D myself and
then only this one that Accord
you could be on that board yeah they
don't even know what braiding is yeah
I'll play the Azeem
I'll play the azim pre move is risky oh
yeah thank you for the game I barely
know the rules
well thank you thank you yes yeah I'm
out there what's Dennis ooh somebody
somebody whether it's happen in our
night playing and eating next to each
other
that guys like a titled kid yeah yeah
he's a title kid you know that is yeah
yeah everybody he's been in the Chess
Club
I am Minnesota uh no Magnus some have
said like that they are as the winds
believe my wins he's the one he's the
one that I think we've all had that
feeling before I'm a long time I got
this I got this with some offense to
Honda Accord I didn't feel like Micah
for this game away in with these
objective not trash he's saying that
yeah I know but I do in telephone what's
fraud stress believe me and only Bob
we've got the desk under court seems
like all our yeah this is exists our
that we're available via text yeah be
text or headset I had it sets them to
get away from you mister man
I did not want to do that you know I
would just give away all myself
Dennis the room is up next Thank You
hundred court I like this under court
that was a biggie who do you want try to
find someone haven't played yet are we
played or to why no play on that this is
blender clean though that's a funnier
name but that's too high rated for
usually on the first okay but then I saw
funnier names
hmm I'm tempted well do it do it
what's well what is what is missing we
know I've been waiting for a train
personally but Gary yeah that's right my
fear if you say so
alright see weakness of the last move
and this is my secret prep and there's a
funny story that goes with it
can you just give me
cute purse a done noobest yes funny
story in the end not gomorrah sub this
to me in specifying gold and a here at
the attend at the mmm-hmm
thousand-dollar would starve it we have
us a of us and not more since the nice
having showed my parallel spencer and i
remember clearly yeah and did you stop
telling stories and just telling to
Moosa I mean who's playing here the I'm
telling the story see you can focus on
the chest
i I'm helping I'm helping you out
usually not really but now I feel helped
okay yeah
everything's fine here this is fun you
can have that item I didn't find this
fun it's worth one point
but I was gonna check it again if I did
what's my rating of wood stacks
okay it's catching up he's catching up
this might be a mess me just put that
out see ya just develop your stuff
golden rules chess player Danny did not
have anything to do with that that was
all Dennis Dennis install additional my
stressing Lee checked a wizard and no
understanding no but now the greatest
weakness of wondering you should have
kept queens on the on the board because
they do another thing
yeah afternoon yeah now they're not
going to know she well she has the queen
of plunder she's not saying mrs. plunder
my queen all the time come on oh yeah
where's Chris Perry he blender to clean
today I said don't blunder your queen
and he plays another game he plundered
his queen
I said don't do that where's Barry he's
over there
is he in the corner it's dark over there
weeping quietly as mocking now we've
plummeted under 100 viewers that's
because I played Bishop oh yeah we need
like two okay yeah all right Mike is
much more magnetic whiskey boring old
Dennis I know well we might have some
new viewers how is the weather in st.
Louis today is a head of a cold day just
it's repaired to the the reason they
suppose it's how do you guys yeah it's
it hasn't been so bad it's been rainy
and whatever but 37 degrees Fahrenheit
whatever positional play Bishop there
what are you excited for Christmas I am
I'm crushing it as a father in this
Christmas I got a nine story Elsa Castle
for my daughter so um it's pretty good
so that happened it happened I'm gonna
have the bishop pair your Denis the roof
so that's it easy yeah easy prep it up
Thank You Larry castle well yeah it was
we went to Target and I said it was
marked down from 300 to 150 dollars so I
didn't personally want to buy it
my wife she uh she convinced me and we
went to the cash register
we went to buy this gigantic castle it's
obviously amazing in love and they said
it was 30 something dollars and then we
said wait what that's too good of a deal
and we looked in there was a sticker
they said it was $25 so we ended up
paying 25 bucks for a 300 dollar nine
story Elsa castle so yeah things are
looking good this Christmas she's a
pretty good story I go don't tell my
daughter by the way she may be listening
to the stream maybe she's dead not
coming home
but she's three so she's probably not
watching the stream
yeah a pleasant illusion I'm kind of
suspicious that the castles past as well
it looks like it was probably a deal
where it's one of those who was opened
and then returned so it might be a
little suspicious but I paid 25 bucks
it's nine story castle so I assumed all
the risks and if a little pieces missing
should probably never know okay good
night everyone take a night Emily Trask
very back in back in the rotation after
the last one was horrible what our
viewership is going down so we need my
comer to come back in strongly Akana see
you're singing I'm which dish at this
one he's you know holding it together
alright ex villager says good night
Emily Exodusters 22 Oh in Baku
everyone's saying good night actually
Bret - yeah - how does he have this
little snowflake Direct Relief charity
on this ball yeah it's good guy Emma
coos is a good guy who's Mike this is
getting our book yeah Baku's won the
challenge yeah yeah yes first first you
earned them because I wrote that on the
facebook must've been under which
disaster those moves no it's your turn
in your moving No
and then it'll do it so where did you
put the makeup remover then you know all
right
you pretty obvious stuff and if it's not
obvious you don't do it but who's
challenged us to crazy house please
let's play chess focus um I also might
come around way so maybe kisses all
right I guess the beauty of the dream
has vanished no it's not over it's never
gonna stop
we're doing this all night we just
started yes yeah wouldn't mind shift
ended like forever ago your shift just
- icon anywhere nobody's going head oh
you you know what I let's be yeah that's
my position all know I man no no I'm
just
alright so we should totally do this
every day like this ha - learning yeah
probably
12 hours a day of this coming oh they're
coming back up there 95 we if we're not
a 100 viewers
I don't think might complain tell a
friend thank you so much for doing that
was great tough okay thank you
please don't don't check him he's gonna
check you you've done oh you guys but
that's a little late it's a little late
just wait okay time I don't know what
that means me more time not you're gonna
lose but your time realize there'd be no
one's who's hitless no laws here nope
Todd the night is dominated that one all
right you're back in this thing not be
three other like spectators watching the
game here should take what I guess they
see it ahead of time I don't know how
that affects our job is again illegal
this is drawn from my cover though
that's not easy still making over King /
King / qø /
yeah what are they gonna make we're
still plummeting so we got to keep this
guy out
don't go too far though they love you
yeah yeah yeah and they're coming
Mondays at 7:30 to your class starting
in January yes I see we have new people
so just keep saying the same stuff cuz
that's funny um we're doing a prep
stream here eventually we gonna have the
Juba dress doing all these streams so
look forward to actual detailed analysis
in that but until then we're doing the
moment yeah be careful pre moving
because I have to take out c6 yeah
they're not going to Queens no technique
should do something more challenging
yeah do you play my converse you get
checkmated I'll tell you those are the
kind of James I like a dozen moves
there's someone else or a casual casual
maybe we need waited one oh do you play
two one nope I knock extreme crushed
crashed no so I'm come here oh good good
yeah come on yeah yeah I mean if you
watch Mike comer I mean the choice is
obvious
c4 I never played the c4 in my life game
aborted gun we didn't have happiness
prep I guess yeah mono rated amber get
that one yes that's our ex friend yeah
or ex friend next back spreads lyrics
and
blunder maybe played this just move I
won't play on this is blunder Queen I
like my chances against this is listen
I'm can be my Queens on the board I can
redeem my are deemed is Mike you do not
ask why there is you are you whispering
is for my commerce and then we do do you
know me do you know hitting don't want
get back web checkmated yeah get that
out of the way challenges ruined yeah
they're doing stuff on the queenside but
with my comer you're getting checkmate
it lets tell you those guys - good yeah
why did you tell me don't play you don't
play you so Dennis play all right here I
come here I come here I come it doesn't
work like I'll pass
I develop fantasy yeah you got this yeah
I don't know what they're not offend
them oh I'll figure something out here
somehow some way I don't like this there
used to be like 10 people in here now
though it's crashing everybody hi
welcome back baby come back there's some
tricky ideas don't worry and I worried
my covers plane school that was not the
best news is you're doing
punching I got one chance here wait what
is happening don't get oh man Mike sits
in here don't the check murdered so
chuck in something you maintain Todd
reviewers yeah oh boy
I'm out of here yeah well come on they
say it's a quick fast primo every move
through go go go go go
take it like a bad persons to good
dentist so whatever I said about you
Madison this is blunder queen yeah now
we thank you oh my god we have to avoid
we have to abort what is this what is
this kids no aunt dama Lord we can buy a
Honda Accord again you can put this
person there you go alright somebody I
could be thank you thank you thank you
yeah if you're in the sixteen seventeen
hundred range please Challenge lower
house my life is a wing I like the wind
I don't like losing ya know if you want
like this guy sits here isn't this
viewer number just goes up and up Mike
yeah yeah because there's no more
variation yep yeah I always knew Mike
would become a GM yeah
it happened today today we're
celebrating with this dream it's
official where you think you go oh and
castle glad even notice he Castle
queenside if I was paying attention are
you out here no he's working all night
playing in the quads playing the quads
okay no play the level Lord he's doing
his laundry
Caleb Debbie come on this is your chance
to crush Caleb dem be who you drew last
I can easy draw the hard workers we stay
we hold it down and you know throughout
the night oh oh that's it but wasn't
sure it wasn't ship it wasn't check if
it wasn't check yeah some people don't
know you're a GM this kind of setting
get out of the poop here comes a check
can you deal with the check you can got
lucky you got lucky
yeah oh it's a it's a trick it's a trick
I'll take my queen please don't take my
horse gentlemen as an obvious suggestion
this is not this is a 1,600 that's too
strong dude slow down this is not you're
like you got three digits then come back
and challenge us what happened to us
what happened to us all right I need
this play somebody can beat and get my
rhythm back okay okay I know I'm miss
right now that's a funny name
oh there you go thank you thank you
thank you
and then once I beat a Welker you know I
get my rhythm back and I beat anybody
dude you better not aboard a welcome you
better zero Vincenzo good thank you all
right the Caledon carny is in the kill
living or who's in here is Nora Nora
just she's a stripper
oh my gosh I always take the pole baby
that's what I heard at you the Lord anon
us yeah so close you almost played I was
not to be I guess we should take that
Mike is that Beth Deacon who's all here
get all these people on the stream
people what mmm whoo ah llama lord said
hi pal bans for profanity I'll allow it
no advance like random stuff like the
chat
it makes no sense he said hi pal that
was banned for profanity
hey so maybe I should stop repeating it
something I don't know about that for
his oh you really ought to play the
llama Lord come on use and permitted oh
it's a permitted term now pal
you can now use that on our stream
that's good to know people that used to
not get the word pal okay now get with
it if you want to talk about how Benko
you can now do it first look short there
and if you lose this game our good
friends look who's will lose his faith
in but Cruz was four seconds you might
News's fast please get at least two
queens at least don't shock mates don't
jerk me these two please it was all for
you
I got two points for that I got two
points well deserved two points
well then yeah thank you a Welker
resistance ladder is this supposed to
just crush them and wait there who's
this I've seen this it's now 12 this
Kramnik student plays a lot on just
crammed experiment who who is it oh
we're dia who it is it's a wait sir we
need Dennis Lord that person hey we
already lost the I don't know but they
said they almost it's what Oh braided
it's 1800 you can do it
all right up 1790 now you play better in
your reading goes up alright what's up
girl something I don't want unit good
three - I guess the play kramnik student
next yeah tough opponent like a 1900
likes last guy please no I've seen this
person that plays on if it's the same
one hmm he's famous and the fucsia once
those two play is Kramnik student cran
Dexter
please play Kramnik himself and then
whatever we send him very pensive when
it's time to play Lord Ananta anonymous
then we send in my color wooden spear
makes you that's a very Coulson
situation yeah he's got a play while
you're hard to hear from fuzzies he's
twelve hundred let him play like a 1300
you want to trade I gotta get my rook
playing oh my gosh stuff you're the best
that's a new verdict as we go oh gosh
just get out of here Queens get out of
here am i up on time yet I'm tired I'm
tied on time then better but above all
faster I do whatever they're gonna leave
all these people whose day you're making
so much happier thank God thank you I
got to get my room oh right there
you can take it good I'm sure I dare you
to take it I dare to take it you got
better got better I he knew he knew he
knew he knew get out of here you're out
of here get out of here I don't like you
I don't like you be nice okay I'll try
I'll try all right oh no no your bishops
all right you got this fast
it's almost feet here all of us be who's
got the fast fingers come on baby
hey stop it come on come on you're up in
time go fast run right take my fish up
please take my [ __ ] right red red red
red red Brian Rodney doesn't matter
checkmate you got this run away hide
hide hide good game of like yo yeah my
15 challenges
Blaine what you probably don't want the
one minute ones to pick for loans is
that play this guy here you go 3-2
against the 52 that's good okay all
right yes right here we go Schrodinger's
cat say yeah thank you for the game Lord
huntin on the none than us
[Music]
hi foxy up that was a banned for
profanity okay this is this is a Perry
Coulson position oh no people want to
crush me no that's true I played like
three games and tired it's like after my
bedtime it's 5:30
I want to play people that don't want
crush me I shared that Mike comer
attitude and you're here to lose to me
than a whole point yeah where's the 1100
set that's what we at this time of day
it's that sort of situation maybe good
feel yeah yeah still pinned you play e5
so I'm gonna try my yeah I mean oh no
this is pretty strong though what
happened I turned away for a second you
know I lose man
trapped yes I'm trapped
just fine just just play the one move
your head all right and let the chips
fall where they may check up to right
now doing a lot of truck y'all know a
lot of trouble you don't wanna trouble
you're in a lot of trouble
alright oh you got other way
you found a way out I'm very impressed
very you don't know Barry still good
oh it's not I'm taking I'm taking was
that night attacking a queen
thank you for tuning in ex villager you
where you were tremendous to the chat we
appreciate you so can I say Merry
Christmas
the snow take it Remo take it yeah yeah
no extra litter think we have one fan we
got one baby nothing else we have one
thing here you lost of your words always
over/under what mike is playing is
always over on I know should I take them
some amounts of Bishops this guy learned
from Queen f6 f6 is asking is there
anybody else upstairs lobbies you want
to play Bobby Fox oh don't tell people
names of people that work here secret
information
yeah do you say Danny people don't know
that Steve's a firing that's something
to look forward to
probably all right good night Lord under
London s and yeah Happy New Year Merry
Christmas geuman res borracho bein so on
the 27th market calendar I don't know
time yet but he'll be he'll be in here
in the stream so we're testing out this
is just a test dream she was going on 3
p.m. USA Central time 3 p.m. for Akopian
doing an actual legit non goofball e
stream here so you know the goofy type
so you might learn stuff I'm like that's
brilliant he's gonna take with the
reputation to show up in them that's you
eat wrapped over you're the best the
guideline d yeah no way they're talking
about no once when I read and but yeah
bar Kobe and Jimin dress yes perfect yep
take the bishop exhibition yep that was
my one little trick anywhere the best Oh
that'll be good yeah it'll be great and
yeah so I mentioned that but every time
we have to do resume getting down here
is go play do we have any rely on this
guy up so I guess they they can't see
Danny but they can hear him and he's
he's the guy seen he's kind of the pub
Bensimon was to our YouTube channel pH
stream the credit success for it so
Danny can you tell us anything about the
next year like what words which I played
here people want to know what's what's
up like what are we expecting a is
coming in the future you try or idle
ahead you can't always play absolutely
but you can always try you try you're
just gonna play Queen c7 and lavage
probably he's gonna play Queen d7
something brilliant joke well 17 the FM
I think you're talking about is a V
Friedman no he doesn't do lectures here
anymore
he does combine stuff sometimes around
your chair check oh thank you okay
I wouldn't never know it neither good
well the only way you know is that
you're like I need to read
Rennie where did read maybe yes mister
define my best he's too strong he
doesn't wish on too much checkmate yet
so just push the pawn yeah oh really
diagonally you don't open them yeah look
that it's hurry up Perry alright let's
try this one again into this org no no
the other one
keep attacking the key that's your only
chance
yeah but this might win a Queen's rice
oh yeah yeah put your coming little
while it's affecting your Queen yes yes
hurry
that's your chance this is your one and
only chance does this say how long this
dream especially 3:15 we're probably
approaching the seven seconds round that
we're over two hours we are over two
hours like at least I didn't get
humiliated no you did you can get like
you get like a little cheery things yeah
it was a little cherry think give us one
cheer when I have for donations we're
just in it print them to your
hallucinations Domino two hours three
minutes how do you know that because
look who's those ivory thing yeah that
symbol subs exclaim subs where's that
damn subs that telltale stuff thumbs and
Express obvious I did nothing
no BOTS
yeah but so far there's been no reason
to ban anything you guys have said so I
do appreciate you guys here the chat you
guys have been doing yeah one that
really has been great you guys have a
couple wonderful strike it's under the
Chevron next to the viewercount one game
when you were on the first one right
yeah so that's a good one Sunday the
stream that's a really go that's a
really good one to win where's this view
count
Stephanie Ben are anonymous rhinos yeah
yeah how long have we been up all
general way of donating but twitch gets
a percentage a bit is a cent sort of oh
yeah we never played for a mixtape
doesn't eat holler yeah yeah we love
donations you know send all your
donations to Mike whatever this thing is
or what is that Facebook Twitter skit
complicated let's get complicated let's
do complicated equals black doesn't on
equality some nobody face all right
moment of truth here moment of truth
wait what's this oh cool is this charity
guy I like my shoes i yeah yeah so he
gave this and then some goes to charity
or something they could give it all that
y'all should have been a little bit
share that's all we are a charity yeah
yeah look at that
because thank you sir look who's is my
man sorry it's all the bits I have left
no worries Baku's thank you very much
you're the bits leader hungry
it's the bits later all right I'm back
in this thing somehow someway take
student Kramnik student would be
delighted to hear there we go here we go
[Music]
nobody cares about that check Megan I
get to play really terrible to achieve
that um yeah seven year fast so they're
cheap moves on my chest are there what I
don't receive treatment on my chest
fast that was sweet that was sweet
yes yes perfect game is let's take it
easy after that one Christian how we
really to standard to want is full to
Isengard
that's my card you bet not being
accurate I said is this something that
we wanted to just easily pick up on to
YouTube
yeah okay cuz what it's like the GM it's
something who it's us I don't know you
can put like the highlights right yeah
that makes a lot of sense I'm always
full of good ideas their beds at night I
need to watch or Mike comer is your way
we stream YouTube what time controllers
challenge one minute is too low kramnik
student please challenge us to one
minute you play my car
you have a trophy on my chest if you're
a top layer trophies oh yeah they do
that yeah some yeah somehow I'm like top
50 standard because I played like one
tournament and beat up a bunch of lawyer
if there's a nice totally manage it yeah
oh yeah I'll take it yeah it's only
trophy I can yeah you beat up a bunch of
people that are like a thousand and then
you get to be like 23 24 hundred I'm not
the standard thing that you definitely
can make sense to me yeah that's my
comfort zone me and also I don't really
play standard mellow after skiing Wow
[Music]
crashing this girl you know they know
maybe about possible you're doing okay
let's just check Chuck well the checks
well so he's one plus one forget about
it always check now 101 oh come on
kramnik student get with the program we
want to play you but you know mm-hmm
check check
no check I should watch you get in that
I did my games I played like three games
I'm the best
Danny get in there yeah Jess yeah no
hand Accord that looks easy Lexie's this
guy's toughest you already played this
person didn't like barely won right
there's no haven't yeah I guess I
rematch you get to me mad she gets very
much but at least I won't take it easy
now cuz I know he's good yeah yeah I
said mean things about all that court if
I take it all back on the hardest wrong
yeah very good very good done see
finally keeping to our diminutive Castle
all right put the bishop on the back row
he never knows what is Chet what is the
appropriate amount of time for a might
come a video this is something we need
to get to the bottom of 40 seconds 60
seconds all your shorts that's all but
if it's this scenario um what would you
guys like to watch because obviously
there's there's some limits like that's
just too much but how much would you
guys actually why oh I missed it I'm
just curious to know cos we just do what
people want their bishops yeah but my
lemon was better anyway Oh watch this
look familiar
push all right good game Honda Accord
boom just we have to determine students
how much time was time control mike is a
102 per star rare yet why no standard
you make you make up check all the boxes
here's the hyper very strong just it's
not good at this time controlling you
guys I got this I got I got super is
double as pawns double ice latest pawns
to all you want to clean yes check super
free and another free pawn stuff plays
like as I'm pre moving for you
now simple conversion simple conversion
easy easy easy the canvas it up it would
you like to trade Queen sir alright
that's fine that's fine we'll get the
Queen trade the old fish
[ __ ] [ __ ] 3 we trade please say that's
checkmate please whoa whoa this is that
was a nice move for the basement way no
one like did it with the wrister ID for
profanity how old are you
that was bad allowing I say you can ask
how old are people on this chat Oh
glasses kisses getting something through
it's all right but they never see that
one coming stop wait oh well who could
be kramnik still mmm good teacher
all right thank you cramming soon we got
that game in one who else wants some
buzzing just yeah well you're now
allowed to ask an archer inappropriate
as profanity um I think it had the
fucsia who is one of these people that's
and they that name in there Simon
members oh I'm watching the stream good
cooker 30 seconds behind in a one-minute
game you gotta crush you cover look at
this look at this you have to crush this
person come on you know win this bike
then you'll lose okay come on Mike you
gotta smile
alright this is this is the game huh
this is the game this is the game now I
imagine this around you play Mike you
get checkmate it but now the clues have
traded some like sauce
gotcha
that's it good good there comes a chick
messing around wasn't that's fine that's
fine I love it I got the two nights
nobody's told me how long my converse
stream should be so I'm just assuming
your last forever at this point I'll see
you here comes another jerk yeah my
nights are awesome yeah if only act
don't like make him eat his words
big trash talker yeah also the night he
doesn't oh I bet it's good to not know
he was protected mmm yeah we'll do a
little bit those dance let's dance
oh the dance is over
check way up until I stop choking move
the screen sounds like a few hustlers
down hold of a twitch channel this is a
very prestigious just you just what um
and yeah it the mood will obviously
change some lunch Miguel these genomes
in here starting on the toy so far and
we'll see what happens I can't wait to
see what happens we get obvious I got
the dog walker got the dumb Rock and
this is the one silly stream before this
yeah this twitch channel becomes super
serious professional nice trick um thank
you game that was a tough one that's a
tough one I find you to get tagged a bit
all right that was I feel like this is
this is winding down but if you want to
I think this all right thank you Mike
Mike is out of here everybody how about
this guy hey well 3 personnel we're down
to one view where Mike left oh down to
one viewer
but yeah
everybody has been great vintage Jeff
yeah it's been a good stream so this
will do it a Welker gets the last game I
play here plays the London Danny to
expert Danny Danny's the expert on the
London this is your last chance to cheat
on the stream here tonight and I gotta
figure out where to put this myself I
gotta be somewhere like weird to mention
okay like you know like 30 seconds ago I
was great fun well done guys
Thank You Percy okay I guess thanks for
the awesome stream look forward to the
next one
yeah um I don't know when if you guys
did like you know the goofball stream we
can do this again we'll throw the
richest err on the side of the world to
see what happens people like it you do
it again that's how it works so thank
you Baku's and also our cheerleader
because leaving us now so thanks for
watching the stream do I have another so
far is before the new year is there
anything else planned 2018 no we're
trying to make it regular because
regular me is like once once a week
right now it's scheduled for lots of you
and it might go up this is always
Thursdays and like for Central Time yeah
okay
so that's sort of the plan four o'clock
Central Time
Thursday's might change it'll change but
uh okay so that's the plan we're running
with people know you want to check out
the great GM content we didn't offer you
today what time is the route stream I
don't know this bridge oh is that some
streamer
you must be sir I lost a piece I think I
did lose a piece we put your schedule
into a public google calendar that
people can integrate in cicero's wow
this is that Machuca is on it will not
let us down what's happening I lost a
piece there's our last game gonna be us
we're gonna try not to
we're not try not to don't try not to
just to lose
hello chespin oh one thank you for
watching the very last game
where's June even then the schedule
changes are immediately visible that's a
good idea
thank you the Fuchs yacht so yeah
there's that's why we're doing this
there's no bunch of probably really good
ideas that we don't know about so yeah
we should just keep doing a couple
practice streams here so that we figure
out what we're doing that's what we're
although just try this
ah just pronto one in slightly too late
so our looking people watch this after
and you can watch it on Twitch on Twitch
inning on Twitch only hey wide variety
of tools available on Twitch this is a
long Lord I trust whatever Caleb says we
should do when will you do this again so
on the 27th for sure four o'clock
Central Time
it's gonna be bar code Ian's doing it
that's gonna be everything that's gonna
be our first very serious stream include
like alerts that show up when people
donate or subscribe yeah we got to
figure all this stuff out we might need
to do another goofball stream just to
figure this out
do we should just test for all the stuff
it's that's something most students have
included umm yeah do we have anything
that Caleb says whatever Caleb Danby
says do that cuz I I we trust in the
Lama Lord
ya know he's a he's a good he's a twitch
streamer so he knows always good I like
the goofball strings me too
we we ought to do it
um do you guys like this format was like
a hundred people that started off on the
show this slowly dwindled few remain um
some people might like that oh yeah so
we better try this again just so we can
test although all the stuff official bit
he doesn't because I know that that [ __ ]
was protective taken all these
protectors I have a crank mate though
try not to great fun news might want to
check out stream labs calm I downloaded
this dream labs OBS Brian okay so we do
that an old-fashioned so they haven't we
haven't we can't use it
yeah until next time yeah I heard down
all right thanks llama Lord now the
season we have to be able to donate
through the twitch account and money can
go straight to a PayPal account I prefer
to watch longer time control so you
sleep ideas yeah that's sort of my thing
I'd be playing a lot of 5 min I played a
couple and you know miss a good - yeah
left to look into all this well yeah so
that's sort of the thing I assume varlet
but maybe it'll be like three but if I'm
gonna name - Prime Minister's ways up -
cuz then Brasher yeah there wasn't a
whole lot of analysis on this is just
apologized but let's don't be bored -
some people like to learn stuff for some
reason so yeah when it tries is a
streamer they trust people that have
been streaming on they seem to know that
yeah but it was a left-wing Mike so was
a laugh it was a laugh I don't know
that's good or bad
I've been waiting for white - between
their leaders are you be here to say
goodbye to everybody when this game
finished just like people might want to
see your face you can that you don't
have to oh that's tough right there they
say every time
every time you say goodbye you die
I'm out I've never heard that in my life
it's a quote yeah you said it
are you feeding masters um let me check
when you survive this I know but how
it's gonna be checkmate if I don't it's
gonna be checkmate if I don Perry is the
master of many things about us on
hanging all the Lord this guy's hanging
that's really okay yeah we're done
you're - oh my god he missed it yeah you
know gonna win the game dude that's the
takeaway yeah very school takes time
yeah yeah yeah my love where's your
majority push it push it
this right here lady five blade master
don't ya
so yeah definitely bar will do his thing
I get that I play fast it yeah you can
take it surviving another well if you
can see where the increment yeah geez oh
but yeah right the increment helps wins
this so well yeah as it wraps up I do
want to thank everybody I don't know how
to end this dream you just put the one
dude to do a leg of your death then
everybody would get sick Danny with
choucas face that's why I look forward
to the best yeah Danny Machuca thank you
for setting this up he's he's Danny as a
master he's the guy so if you ever watch
a lot of our commentary sometimes he's
the executive producer of a lot of stuff
along with Ben Simon and Isaac Trent's
so by going on behind the scenes here
still fighting on which is good you give
this a lot of time you say goodbye
it looks like everybody's gone so it's
just just three people down the room
he's no I'm gonna lose we do look
forward to doing some sorta stay tuned
thanks just immigrant I lose how do I
lose no hey Walker you better give you
big a cookie so alright thank you
everybody for checking out our stream
tonight my boring from coming a lot of
good stuff coming I rolled that video
gave us all right well that's cool yeah
goodnight everyone
goodnight my one three it's not good
we're gonna record shots those Reno